PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to Deconstructing Chatbots.
I am Priyanka Vergadia,
and in today's episode,
we are going to explore
how to integrate Dialogflow
with Telephony Gateway.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The other day, I was talking
to a friend about chatbots.
And he said, Priyanka,
it would really
help me if I could just assign
a phone number to the chatbot
that I already have
built. That way
I can provide the same
experience to my users
across the phone and web.
Well, that led me
to this episode.
So today, we are going to
work with the same appointment
scheduler chatbot that we
built in the previous episodes
and integrate it with
the Telephony Gateway
so our users
calling on the phone
can get the same experience
as the ones on the web.
Now, remember that this
is a feature in beta
so you may want to let us know
how you're using it so that we
can keep improving it.
Let's get in our
Dialogflow console
and locate our agent,
Appointment Scheduler,
with our intents.
We are going to go into
integration section
where we enabled our web
and Google Home integration.
This time we will select
Dialogflow Phone Gateway.
It allows you to select the
country for the phone number.
And in next step, you
choose the phone number.
I'm good with the
default selection,
and we'll just finish it here.
Once you finish, you'll see
the Congratulations message
indicating a phone
number that's assigned
to your bot for your
users to call in.
Now as you can see in yellow,
the phone number you get
is valid only for 30 days if
you're using Standard Edition.
If you are a business,
you definitely
want a permanent number.
So for that, you should be
using Enterprise Edition.
Let's place a call to our
bot at 267-281-5159, which
is the number that we assigned.
CHATBOT: Hello.
How can I help you?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Schedule an appointment
for 4:00 PM tomorrow.
CHATBOT: What services
are you looking to get?
DMV offers driver license and
vehicle registration services.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Driver's license.
CHATBOT: You are all set
for your driver's license
on the 25th of January 2019
at 16 hours zero minutes
and zero seconds.
See you then.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: All right.
So my friend is really
happy now that he can just
assign a phone
number to his chatbot
and provide the same experience
across web and phone channels.
Don't miss the next episode
of Deconstructing Chatbots
because we are going to
learn more about entities.
If you like this
video and would like
to see more of this content
then please like and subscribe
to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]